James noticed from looking at your body
of work that several of the films
feature life and death pretty heavily
that's a prominent theme in a lot of
your movies why is that when a lot of
people might be too squeamish they want
to talk about other things sci-fi
something happier whatever well I think
that you can feature life and death in
any genre I think that in many ways even
if you look at screenwriting tropes that
film is about life and death
but for me I believe artistically it's
important to tell the things that you
know best and for me life and death and
the themes of life and death or
something that for better or worse have
been very prominent in my life
my father died when I was 13 of an
unknown illness the CDC was involved and
thought it was perhaps the first
American case of SARS and so no one knew
what to do with it he went from perfect
health to dying in a week and they were
concerned that myself my mother and my
sister anyone he had come in contact
with might carry it and might cause
something infectious because they had
tried literally all of the different
antibiotics and all the different
treatments and nothing worked nothing
responded he just got constantly worse
and worse and worse and he died the
exact minute that he was admitted the
previous week so when you have something
like that happen and I had a very happy
childhood for the record it was a
wonderful time a place where I was able
to be imaginative and creative and and
foster that my parents were both
teachers and growing up in a town of 123
people in rural South Georgia I was able
to live in a place that community was
very important which I think is also
very important to film and imagination
was nurtured and fostered because I
wasn't living somewhere like Los Angeles
where everything's already imagined for
you where you're always with people of
different cultures different backgrounds
living at urban place when you're a
rural community you have to imagine a
lot of things for yourself
and so for me going through that
experience it really has left an impact
on my life and also on what I want to do
with my career because
that was unexpected that was something
that was not planned and it made me
realize at a very early age the value of
time and what we do with it so because
you are a young director and you've
traveled around the world you've been
involved with so many projects do you
think seeing how things can be taken
away so quickly so unexpectedly lit a
fire under you to do so many things that
maybe some would have planned around and
waited for the perfect time when there
really isn't a perfect time no you're
right there isn't a perfect time for
anything I think that at the end of the
day as a filmmaker you can make excuses
for what you choose to do and choose not
to do but you've got to always have
projects ready at whatever stage in your
career you might be at say you're
waiting on a big project so in that for
over the past year I've been waiting on
a film that I've been developing for a
while that looks like it's going to move
forward this year I ran off to make this
documentary a few things about cancer a
small film that didn't need much of a
budget because I believe you always have
to be making and creating don't throw up
barriers as to what you can and can't do
so certainly for me in my own career
that experience with my father's death
has really motivated me to constantly be
creating them working all the time so it
sounds like there was James life up
until 13 and then a new chapter
once 13 hit and so that time as dark as
it was how did it kind of maybe did you
turn inward did you really start like
going inward and forming this
imagination because of that you know and
I'm sure there's a small town and maybe
people are in your business maybe that's
good maybe that's bad maybe they're
helpful maybe not but how did that shape
your sort of creativity in that time
because I'm sure you could go many ways
with it well I was a kid I always was a
pretty creative individual I had
spent most of my childhood writing and
creating things there's this wonderful
game that came out when Windows 95 was
released on our packard-bell
computer tower that was called spiderman
cartoon maker i don't know if anyone
else played spider-man cartoon maker but
it was a wonderful game all you did was
you would take all these stock scenes
these stock locations characters visual
effects and you would create movies out
of them little animated 2d very simple
animation films and so my sister and I
would go on spiderman cartoon maker and
make sequels upon sequels upon sequels
to these chronolog stories using all
these spiderman characters and that's
how I would tell stories I really wish I
could have figured out a way to capture
all of those because some of them are
pretty hilarious in hindsight but
unfortunately you have to be able to run
the program to open up all the files you
can't export them like you can now so
that was you know a big part of my
childhood growing up and then of course
using my imagination a small town I
would do things like tell stories when I
was growing up my parents bought me a
tape recorder and when we went driving
on long trips I would talk about all
these characters I had invented in my
head and and play like a radio play and
they would record these on cassette
tapes so I had this little you know
little thing that keep in the back seat
and I would talk about these characters
and do these things one time we were
coming back from my grandmother's house
in Florida and I did a 10 hour funeral
for one of the characters who was
resurrected the next day and somewhere
that tape exists I have no idea where it
is but I'm sure it's hilarious as well
but those things were formative in my
childhood and so stories and and doing
things that had to do a storytelling was
something that I was already doing once
I became a teenager and once my father
passed I did turn inward for a time
and and then started turning outward to
kind of figure out ways to express
myself and I think that has really
formulated the person I am today
you